what the vaccine enables people to go
along with more easily is the idea of a
health passport or vaccine passport and
that passport becomes a gateway to a
digital ID that's connected to your
ability to participate in society so it
is the beginning of a social credit
system it is the back door into a social
credit system you're going to need to
have some way to prove you're vaccinated
if we're going to have freedom to travel
so the biggest reason to get a vaccine
passport going is many countries are
saying you can't come in here unless
you're vaccinated
welcome to episode 130 of the Michaela
Peterson podcast in this episode of
opposing views I had Arthur Kaplan and
James Lindsay on to discuss covid-19
vaccine passports we cover topics like
the passport proposals themselves
current restrictions in different U.S
states the potential impact of
amplifying governmental control and the
social Credit Systems James Lindsey my
first guest is an American Author
cultural critic and mathematician who's
spent a significant amount of time in
woke culture especially among writers or
in the written community
he had the opportunity to study you
could say the main tenets of their
literature and to gain a broader
perspective on social changes both in
the US and worldwide
Arthur Kaplan is a professor and
founding head of the division of medical
ethics at NYU Grossman School of
Medicine his focus is on research and
bioethics transplantation and health
reform so these topics are right up his
alley you'll see he had a very different
perspective on what's behind vaccine
passports so make sure you stick around
long enough to see that contrast it's
really interesting and do remember to
hit subscribe if you enjoy this episode
or the opposing views format or want to
see more
James Lindsay welcome to the podcast
great thanks for having me
this should be a good one before we get
started can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
that's a mysterious topic it's harder
than you think to give a brief
background of who I am and what I do I
have a PhD in math and before that I get
a degree in physics so my background
educationally is in the Sciences the
hard Sciences in mathematics so lots of
you know formal logic Etc uh lots of
pattern recognition
um that kind of thing what
mathematicians do I guess and uh
through the course of the previous
decade I stumbled into this woke stuff
happening and I started to think that it
was absurd and so together with a
colleague Peter pagosian we decided that
they were right before an academic hoax
in 2016 and 17 which we wrote and it was
called the conceptual penis as a social
construct we submitted that and it was
accepted by a very low ranking
potentially predatory Journal probably
predatory Journal called cogent social
sciences
it's really funny it turns out it's
going to be one of the funniest things
I've ever what was it called the
conceptual penis as a social construct
so the argument was that penises don't
really exist but that they cause all the
problems in the world including climate
change and so we should think of them as
a social construct that leads to
machismo bragadocio in all men and uh
it's really lewd it's really
horrifically uh lewd piece of academic
writing and it we sent it to a journal
that did not accept it and then they
forwarded it internally to what amounts
to a predatory Journal under the same
publishing company and so there was a
scandal there but we picked it the wrong
Scandal and said that we had pulled a
satire on gender studies and made a big
big hay out of that and we got a lot of
criticism and we took that criticism
seriously both friendly criticism and
not so friendly criticism in fact vile
criticism we took we just took that as a
we didn't take it personally we just
took it as a road map so oh if we want
to prove our point about gender studies
and woke scholarship in general
that's what we have to do to satisfy the
other side they told us what it would
take so let's do that so then we spent
all of 2017 and 18 writing 20 more
academic papers
um
the you know the most famous of these is
about that we can control rape Culture
by studying dog sex in in the dog park
and how people react to it those human
reactions to queer performativity and
canine rape culture and urban dog parks
in Portland Oregon was the title of that
paper and we concluded that we should
train men though that we train dogs we
rewrote a chapter of Hitler's Mein Kampf
as intersectional feminism that was
accepted by a social work Journal we
ended up getting seven papers accepted
one of which the dog sex paper won an
award for excellence in scholarship by
the leading journal and the discipline
and we did that in the course of a
little over a year and at that point we
became International spokespeople for
what in the world is going on in woke
scholarship so we figured you know it
was a crash course to do that we didn't
know woke scholarship well when we
started but obviously we got good enough
where we could publish at the research
level so we knew a little bit by the
time we were done with that project so
Peter diverted his energies into another
project he had had on the back burner
and Helen pluckrose and I uh the other
of our Trio
set to really digging into the woke
literature and I'd keep describing it as
saying it's like if you bought a new
property kind of out in the woods and
you you know you clean up the shed and
you clean up this and you you know tidy
up that and you fix the Garden or you do
whatever and you get the house in order
but there's been that tarp over
something in the backyard and you've
just left it to last and you finally
look under the tarp and you're like
whoop dead bodies and it was like
finding dead bodies to the the dead
bodies rotting in the well really
poisoning our society to see what was in
the scholarship and so I remember at
that time saying oh my gosh you know
this is like
possibly civilizational
collapse
somebody has to do something about this
and so I actually quit my job and
started studying this stuff full time
like I was attempting to independently
do you know PhD level research to
understand and reading papers and books
reading them multiple times taking notes
trying to learn
everything I can as fast as I can about
the the woke scholarship the critical
social justice scholarship and I started
a company at the beginning of 2020 uh
kind of media and information I don't
know a media platform or something
called new discourses it's at new
discourses.com where I basically take my
what I'm learning and put it out in the
world as fast as I can publish it so
pardon the typos I don't have time to
edit and so uh
so I'm trying to get this information
out of the world as fast as possible so
my background is mathematician turned
prankster turned horrified by what I saw
turned probably the I would say it's
it's fair to say that I may be a leading
if not the leading scholar on most
things woke literature but especially
critical race Theory from outside of the
umbrella of people who believe it and
I've been doing that full-time ever
since and now I travel all over the
place and tell people not just putting
it on the internet
okay wow that was a wild story you know
like whether to laugh or to cry
I travel as much as your dad was but
it's like it's a significant fraction uh
you know I've had nearly 80 flights this
year uh and that's with covert and
everything else so I've been getting
around
wow okay well I brought you on this
episode to talk about vaccine passports
can do specifically uh and I chose you
because you've got a logical mind I
thought you'd
you show one side properly so I think we
should Jump Right In that's pretty
intense though that's pretty intense
okay so first off starting with vac the
mandatory vaccine passports that you see
popping up everywhere so my first
question here is according to you is
this uh vaccine mandate and these
passports is it the end is it the end of
covid or the beginning of something
worse it's the beginning of something
worse the covet's irrelevant to it I
mean it's now the evidence is come out
nearly
incontrovertibly it's just absolutely
conclusive that there's what was a
Harvard study that came out just last
week and it said that there's no
statistical correlation of any
meaningful uh stature between
vaccination rates or vaccination
percentages in different countries or
states and rates of covid we see
so-called breakthrough cases all kinds
of all over the place natural immunity
got completely ignored
um they still want vaccines even if you
have negative tests you get your vaccine
you still have to wear a mask not a mask
doesn't do anything in the first place
almost I mean very very little and so
it's all pretext it's all pretext but
what a vaccine does or not the vaccine
itself what the vaccine enables people
to go along with more easily is the idea
of a health passport or vaccine passport
and that passport becomes a gateway to a
digital ID that's connected to your
ability to participate in society so it
is the beginning of a social credit
system is is the back door into a social
credit system like what we see in China
which is effectively totalitarian under
theirs that it's not to say that people
in China can't live a relatively good
life but they are bound by this they
have to say the right things not say the
wrong things they have to spend time
with the right people not spend time
with the wrong people they have to you
know do all these kinds of things to
manage their social credit score or they
find that their ability to use their
their resources their money or whatever
or to take a trip or to get on a train
or to get on a plane or whatever it
happens to be can be pretty severely
curtailed it can be very easily expanded
to the point where depending on your
social credit score things cost more or
less for you it could be a you know a
discount rate if you have a good
propaganda score
um because that's how you raise your
social credit scores behaving the way
the government tells you to and
sometimes literally by watching
propaganda videos on your device and so
if you participate in this they can make
it to where your groceries cost 50 less
and if you refuse to purchase straighten
this or if you go against it they might
cost 50 more and so they can really put
a lot of social leverage on people also
they ban things like people getting
together in large numbers unless it's
government sanctioned and there's
government representatives there
watching it it is the back door to
something far worse the vaccine itself
whether it's absolutely worthless
whether it's slightly valuable whether
it's extremely valuable turns out to be
irrelevant to this question the the
vaccine is not going to end the pandemic
because the pandemic is being used to
install social control and the social
control is being used basically to
leverage people those of whom have the
vaccine so they shrug their shoulders
and say well I already have it so I
already have the vaccine so whatever uh
to get the vaccine passport the vaccine
passport is designed to get people to
start to participate in something
digital in their phone that's connected
to their ID that controls their ability
to participate in society to buy into
sell to go and to travel to enter and to
you know leave you see for example and
what is it in Ottawa and Canada and all
over Australia you can't leave unless
you you do all the things they tell you
you get vaccinated and do all this other
other stuff
um so there's total is this a backdoor
total social control system which will
begin there there and if they can if
they can do it for whether or not you've
taken an injection they can start to do
it for other things it could be your
body mass index it could be whether or
not you are uh you know did you support
the January 6th Insurrection in some way
online well now you're a domestic
terrorist are you a mother or a father
showing up to a school board and
complaining about what they're teaching
well now you're a domestic terrorist and
so if you have a digital passport system
that can control your access to society
it's very easy to put a lot of pressure
and leverage on those people we are
seeing the dawn of totalitarianism in
the west and the vaccine passport is the
back door to it the vaccine itself
clearly the the data have come in is not
adequate to end the pandemic as it were
and in fact it's seeming to be that it
may actually be making it worse it's
probably driving if you understand
biology it's driving the variance the
variance may become worse or less bad
depending on how evolutionary processes
work and in the this case
antibody dependent enhancement can make
some very scary variants that may be
coming down the pike and so everything
about this
it seems to be pretext and the pretext
is for what well the passports and the
passports are for what a back door to a
social control system like we see and
the model exists like we see in China
okay so then what's your response to
people that say that sounds like a very
complicated conspiracy theory that it's
already happening
and it literally published that this is
the intention
um if you go to the world economic Forum
website it's actually on there there's a
there was a book written in I think in
the 40s called the open conspiracy that
suggests that you can get away with a
gigantic scary conspiracy if you just
talk about it because then people think
well conspiracy would be happening in
secret behind closed doors they wouldn't
tell us that they must have some other
intention and so that's
um what I would say to that is it's it's
out it's not even hidden you know the
the the director of the world economic
Forum Claus Schwab at the very beginning
of the pandemic on candlelake quickly
published a book called by June of last
year published a book called covid-19
The Great reset where he explains that
we have a very narrow window to reset
the entire world and its economy and its
approach to social management and
everything
through covid-19 and
this is
that's not a conspiracy that's actually
an organization that's openly telling
you what their goals are and why they're
doing it
um
if they don't want to believe that I
guess that's on them but I encourage
them to go read it this is the same
thing with the so I'm famous with the
woke literature right and I always like
literally sitting here right next to me
right next to me I have a famous woke
education book why because if you follow
my podcast most of what I do on my
podcast I don't sit here and talk to
this microphone and just pontificate I
read the woke literature to people and
say what I think about it and I always
encourage people listen don't believe me
there's a great chance I'm wrong I think
most people most people are well
intended and kind of dumb that includes
really smart people and so we make
mistakes we get things wrong I encourage
people then to go read it for themselves
I I give people access to the degree
that it's legal you know I can't give
people the books I can't publish
republish a book but you know I give
people access this is the book I took
this from go read it yourself see if you
draw the same conclusion draw your own
conclusion argue with me discuss with me
whatever it is same thing with this go
read read what Klaus Schwab has written
about the fourth Industrial Revolution
what classov has written about covid-19
in the great reset what the world
economic forum is doing what how all of
this ends up aligning with the so-called
build back better program that we don't
just hear from Joe Biden or from Justin
Trudeau we hear it from Boris Johnson we
hear it from an uncanny number of world
leaders all kind of in in unison all at
once uh you can actually read these
things yourself and if you wanted
disagree that's fine but I seriously
encourage people to actually go read
what's written first the cloud Schwab's
books are not hard to read they're just
annoying because they're all kind of
that empty corporate jargon but they're
not hard to read I read the great reset
and quote covid-19 the great reset and
something like you know half a day or
something it's not a difficult book and
you can just see it go to his website go
to the world economic Forum website and
see what they're publishing it's
constantly like you're going to eat bugs
you're going to live in a pod you know
all this weird like
they put out a video in 2016 in fact it
said after the great you know to
advertise for the great reset a video it
went viral and I said the first thing
you know coming by 2030 or whatever
what's the future going to look like
they said you will own nothing and you
will be happy everything you have will
be will be rented Western values will
have been pushed beyond their breaking
point now they literally list six or
eight points of just crazy stuff that
people would say is a total conspiracy
theory
um I encourage people to just go engage
with it see what you think why did they
put this ask the question simply be open
why did they put this out why on Earth
are people like you know they made a
video not that long ago where they had a
whole bunch of people like in a room and
it said like you know the great reset
whatever and it's got a picture of Joe
Biden it's got a picture of George W
bush it's got a picture of Ivanka Trump
like there those are the people involved
what's going on just go look for
yourself then watch the scary video that
they tell you what they're talking about
what they're doing constantly warning
about cyber the Schwab's been warned
about the virus before there's a virus
he warned about cyber attacks before
there were cyber attacks he warned about
supply chain disruptions before there
were supplying changes disruptions
if it's not
if it's not a conspiracy that's fine but
you should probably go look at it at
least before you just dismiss it out of
hand these guys have been publishing
this crap since the 70s telling people
what their what their plans are so I
encourage what would I say to people who
say that sounds like conspiracy theory I
would say go read what they've written
about it just go read in their own words
major organizations that are tied up
with major corporations Larry Fink of
BlackRock is deeply embedded in this for
example and see what's there just see
that's horrifying I regret doing this
podcast so early in the morning
[Laughter]
do you think the reason that this is
being so say say this is true and this
is being implemented is the reason it's
being implemented to keep people safe
I mean what do you mean by safe I don't
mean to be the philosopher in the room
but yes uh their goal their
justification is through safety
because they believe as the neo-marxists
pointed out for example Max horchheimer
pointed out that freedom and Justice
these being kind of key words are
dialectical Concepts that's what he said
the exist in contradiction so that the
more freedom that you have the less
Justice that you have and the more
Justice that you have the more freedom
that you're the less the more Justice
the less freedom and back back and forth
and so max horheimer actually said this
he was the third director of the
Frankfurt School of critical theory he
is the person who named critical theory
he invented the idea of critical theory
out of Marx's critical philosophy uh he
said that he was correcting for some of
the errors of Marx one of Marx's errors
he said was that freedom and Justice uh
are dialectical and Marx thought that
you would as you get more Justice you
will get more freedom and this is where
you have to understand that Justice
Means Justice according to communist
terms so Justice Means communism so what
he's actually saying is that
if you want Justice is going to contain
safety if you want to if you want to
look at that safety and and and freedom
are in opposition to one another
and so to keep people safe or to exert
social control are really in some sense
part and parcel the same thing it's just
a matter of justifications
and so this is like I said that's 1969
when horkheimer explained that in an
interview and as he said his entire
critical theory is based on that so yes
the justification is to keep people safe
just like before the French Revolution
the it was the the Committee of Public
Safety that did the Reign of Terror uh
it was to keep people safe it was for
their best interests you know the
technocrats or the aristocrats whoever
it was it was going to keep everybody
else safe on their terms and that's what
it really boils down to is that they're
going to keep people safe from
themselves because they think that
they're smarter than everybody in the
Little Lords of the Earth or whatever
else and that they're going to you know
tell people what it requires of them to
be safe it's not very safe for example
if they're social unrest so what do you
have to do you have to figure out ways
to completely do kind of the the
Socialist redistribution program
not just economically but now in terms
of power and privilege and access we
call it equity and so now we're going to
have worldwide Equity programs that
redistribute resources power privilege
et cetera not just access to the means
of production and uh that will help
stabilize things oh well if we're going
to keep people safe we have to keep them
safe from these viruses I just saw that
Spain came out and said that it's not
enough to wear masks for
um covid we have to continue to do this
until we Stamp Out the flu now
so now we have to continue all of this
medical tyranny because of the flu
which has obviously been a thing which
people have been living with for a very
long time and I saw another uh
article just yesterday or the day before
that said we didn't just you know take
precautions against covet we basically
Stamped Out the flu they say that the
flu didn't happen in 2020 they have
documented I think quite falsely I have
a personal reason for believing this
that there were some 2000 cases of flu
in the past year of course the PCR test
that they were using at the number of
Cycles the detection sensitivity that
they were running it can't really
distinguish coveted from flu and so how
many yeah yeah so do you have that issue
and then simultaneously
I got the flu
so this is what I don't understand I
just told you in a minute ago that I
travel all over the country talking all
over the place I go to all these
meetings all these conferences I'm in
contact with hundreds or thousands of
people regularly somehow it appears that
despite there being Millions upon
Millions upon millions and oh my gosh
pandemic numbers of cases of covid
I somehow managed not to get covered
with all of these huge Public Super
spreader events or whatever that I went
to but there are only 2 000 cases of flu
but somehow I got the flu
that's weird how did I get something
literally that rare and I got I mean I
actually thought I had coveted so I went
to the doctor and I got diagnosed I had
the flu and so uh you know they did the
test and flew so I and it felt like flu
and it acted like flu and it probably
was flu and so
you know
what are they trying to keep us safe
from they're trying to keep us safe from
everything you know the and of course
it's one of your your dad's best
messages is that you're always in this
kind of trade-off between between risks
right it's one of the things I admire of
his message the most is that
um
there's a risk in trying to protect
yourself and there's a risk in not
trying to protect yourself if we're
going to put it into specific context so
if you if you don't protect yourself
from flu then you might get flu you're
taking that risk but if you decide to
protect yourself from flu or covid or
car accidents or whatever else then
you're going to take a different risk
and the risk that we take with regard to
these things is destroying our
livelihoods destroying our economy uh
massive amounts of of death by Suicide
from people who have been socially
isolated for so long and feel like
there's no way out massive increases in
substance abuse overdose deaths other
deaths of Despair
um we see now although you're not
allowed to mention them they apparently
don't exist vaccine injuries
uh the the vares data is granted it's
not uh rigorously collected it's anybody
can go file a claim so it's a quite open
question of what's in there to some
degree but the virs data is concerning
and oddly enough they're pretending that
the various data is not concerning and
so there's a trade-off of risks and so
they say it's about safety but the
question is you know what are we trying
to keep ourselves safe from and what are
we losing or what do we what are we
paying with to buy that alleged safety
so maybe we do make ourselves safe from
flu but is it worth say all having to
stay living in our own houses in
borderline never being allowed to leave
and having to make sure that you know
stores don't really exist for us to go
out into the Public Square and interact
in person because we can just order it
on Amazon have it delivered which is to
Amazon's great benefit of course
um
what are we losing in order to buy that
safety and the the thing is is you
always have to ask where is that
reasonable line
where is the reasonable line where are
you going to say no the risk is worth it
the risk to think for yourself the risk
to take your own action there is to get
in a car even though it's one of the
most dangerous things most people do on
a day-to-day basis even though they
don't think about it the risk to get in
a car and drive where you will under
your own power you know they can take
that away in the name of safety as well
we could either just curtail how much
people drive by making it very expensive
through odd gasoline taxes or mileage
taxes like they're attempting in the
United States you could also transition
to driverless cars and so your car
drives itself maybe it doesn't even have
a steering wheel that you can control
they get the AI technology sufficiently
good then what while you get in your car
and you say well I want to go to the
grocery store and you push it in there
and for some reason they don't want you
to go to the grocery store and your car
drives you to the police station instead
where you're questioned for something
you put on Twitter
and you can't control your car because
you don't have the freedom to control
your car because your car isn't driven
by you what are you trading I'm not
saying that it's necessarily going to
happen that's certainly possible
it's or you know even with these cyber
attacks from the cloud Schwab due to
cyber attacks like a Cyber attack your
car drive you off a bridge somebody
could hack your self-driving car and
kill you what are you trading in the
name of safety and what you are often
what you're often trading is another
kind of unsafety you're you're putting a
different risk into the equation and
people are not usually good at think
unfortunately thinking through and
balancing risks and saying some level of
risk is always going to happen so
therefore some level of risk always has
to be acceptable and that in fact what
causes the most happiness and
flourishment is to allow people to make
the decisions for themselves about how
much risk they're willing to take for
example if you're afraid of covid and
you want to get the vaccine and you want
to wear two masks and a face shield and
whatever else and do you want to dress
on a garbage bag I've seen somebody
wearing PPE in public before which is
hilarious
good that's your decision that's your
decision you want to have or you never
want to leave your house I have a family
member who left his house nine times
during the during the entire uh time
from pandemic lockdown in March of 2020
until the vaccine was available to him
in summer of 2021 so for something like
14 months he left his house wow nine
times if that's what you think you need
to feel safe that's a decision you
should be able to make of course what
was the trade-off you know he lost all
that opportunity a year of his life to
spend time with friends to connect to
get out whatever mental health toll that
took on him I don't know
um
that but there's a trade-off there but
if that's what you want to do to feel
safe that's your choice and if you want
to take a reasonable risk that's also
your choice of course we do have laws
like traffic laws to minimize certain
types of risk uh because we have learned
some lessons the hard way but
I think that there is a very open space
for a lot of debate about what level of
risk you allow people to think for
themselves and choose for themselves and
take that's just getting swept off the
table
over a virus that
is even though it's imminently
survivable is routinely being compared
to smallpox which is not imminently
survivable
okay
the vaccine passport that's
being introduced or that's here do you
know what differences it makes to people
so if you have the vaccine what are you
allowed to do and does that differ by
state and if you're not vaccinated what
kind of freedoms are you losing well I
mean in the U.S
um as far as I know only the state of
New York
and maybe mostly only New York City and
then Los Angeles are actually
implementing these in practice so far so
like I live in Tennessee we don't have I
don't there are no coveted policies here
that have any meaning as far as I'm
concerned or I'm aware uh I never wear a
mask anywhere except on airplanes
um and to go through security in an
airport nowhere else and it's just not
part of my life now if I go to New York
you know they're very strict and to get
into places you actually have to have
the vaccine and there it's down to
individual enforcement
um so we're not all the way I know
Canada is a little bit different but
we're not all the way at the at the
level of passports they've attempted it
in New York City I think they're about
to attempt it in Los Angeles and
otherwise the rest of the United States
does not have that but they do have
these weird mandates in different
employment sectors some of which are
more real than others Joe Biden for
example does have the authority to
mandate the federal employees who are
under his purview
should be met it can be mandatorily
vaccinated
um he does not however have the
authority to say that my private company
may be named Amazon can mandate I don't
own Amazon just full disclosure uh it
can mandate their employees to be
vaccinated so people think that though
because of this whole you know OSHA
thing but it turns out that that was
just a press release and so far and I
know that because there are lawyers
who've been waiting to sue the federal
government for this mandate and they
can't sue because there's actually no
official thing they just did a press
release and said that they're going to
do it and then companies started doing
it
even though there's no legal apparatus
requiring them to which sort of sucks
for those companies again safety and
trade-offs right because those companies
believe they're taking a move that
lowers their liability will presume by
and for getting people to get vaccinated
or acquiring their employees to get
vaccinated if they have more than 100
employees but the legal apparatus that
would would take away their legal
responsibility if something goes wrong
was not actually put in place so the
companies want to be left holding the
back
that was a press release everything's
fake this is all fake I hate to sound
like a lunatic there's so much of this I
mean after having again we can go back
to the woke literature I invoke the
critical theorists and now I'm going to
invoke the post-modernists
I'm going to invoke John boder yard who
talked about through the 80s about this
idea of simulation simulacrum and and uh
hyper reality and Hyper reality is this
kind of fake reality that's more real
than real it's a it's a it's a
propaganda creation is what it is and he
was thinking largely but not entirely he
was thinking largely at the time of you
know marketing where you have the
airbrushed model and she looks hotter
than hot and it's you know whatever not
she looks more more feminine than female
allows in reality because she's
airbrushed and she's you know
photoshopped into you know put a little
extra hip on her slim that waist a
little bit you know let's make those
eyes really like perfectly shine or you
know more real than real and so he was
kind of thinking of that but he also
wrote a series of essays during the Gulf
War that were collected into a book
that's titled the Gulf War did not take
place
and what he argues in that book is it's
not that there weren't incidents and in
fact atrocities that were taking place
in the Middle East and so it's that what
we were presented with
through CNN and the other media outlets
in our governments was not what was
really taking place we were given The
Truman Show version of a real
thing that was happening in the Middle
East and the thing that is called the
Gulf War was the the
production that was his argument so
we're not looking at the real thing
we're looking at a fake creation around
the real thing that drives a narrative
and he actually in fact said that the
Gulf War did not take place he said the
Gulf War is an atrocity masquerading as
a war
and so
this has been picked up what's happened
is the people who are in power right now
whether it's through the woke or whether
it's in conjunction with the woke or
whether it's the so-called regime or the
overstate or this whatever we we might
want to call the hyper Elites who seem
to be doing a bunch of weird stuff uh in
many countries all at once simultaneous
you know very simultaneously to where
everything seems to be happening once
everywhere at once they have seen the
tools they in fact they've seen the
warnings that were given by both the
critical theorists and the
um postmodernists especially and said
these are weapons and they've picked
them up and they've started to use them
and so where Boatyard was in despair
warning about the state of the world in
which it's possible to create a hyper
real or a pseudo-real image of what's
actually happening in the world into
manicure and control that through
propaganda and repetition and marketing
and because he hated capitals it had to
be marketing and everything else
um
if you flip that over and you get The
Truman Show where if you you know the
basic plot is Jim Carrey's character
Truman doesn't know that he's actually a
character in a television show where he
lives in a town that's not even real the
whole he's lived his entire life in a
town that doesn't exist because it's
actually a sound stage and at the end
you know he ends up on a boat and he
crashes into the edge of the Sound Stage
and finds out that his entire reality is
fake and then the audience watching is
you know fought has 30 years or 40 years
has fallen in love with this character
uh outside of The Truman Show this
Truman and do they
are they aghast at the fact that it's
all fake and that they've been
manipulating Truman and all that no
they're just more enthralled with this
with the the hyper real story being told
that's really kind of
um
what we're dealing with and so you know
the Biden Administration comes out it's
just like when they did the the
extension on the uh eviction moratorium
Biden said we don't have the authority
to do this we'll just do it anyway it'll
buy us time
so from covid they made an eviction
moratorium where you couldn't evict
people if they didn't pay their rent say
to their landlord the landlord had no
legal response to throw them out and so
it was going to expire I think at the
end of July but it may have been June
but I'm pretty sure it's the end of July
this year it was set to expire they let
it run the clock run down to a crisis so
that they could then come out and say
you know Congress never acted blah blah
blah and then Biden came out with an
executive order saying well we're going
to extend this eviction moratorium even
though it's a legislative decision not
an executive decision so he technically
couldn't do it and he said we'll get the
CDC to do it for us so we'll use an
administrative apparatus which is under
the executive branch to do it and so
they they extended it but even said it's
unconstitute we know it's
unconstitutional for us to do it but
it'll buy us time it's all fake it's all
just manipulations they're just
completely creating a fabrication of
what's really going on and I actually
think that that we're in a very
interesting time in history very much
like after the printing press was
invented the Internet being our analog
in which the powers are realizing that
the mechanisms by which they maintained
power are literally being dissolved out
from under them and so now they're
trying desperately to use those tools
whether through selective censorship
whether through uh threatens of of
banning people from social media for
saying the wrong things for example by
trying to change definitions very
rapidly by putting things out that are
are just as they say in professional
wrestling kfabe
um which is when you know it's fake and
the audience knows if it's fake but you
all pretend it's real anyway
um
they're doing this I think in a
desperate attempt to maintain control
and if you look at that world economic
Forum stuff that I was telling people
that you go read a minute ago through
that lens all of a sudden it kind of
also makes sense this Super Hyper Elites
realize their power is about to be swept
out from under them and
by creating a state like you have in
China where there's total information
control you can keep that thing under a
lid
Okay so
I guess any skepticism I have towards
and I'm I'm not that skeptical but any
skepticism I have towards something like
this would be
I think the average person is not
capable of doing very much I don't think
people are that bright and this is huge
so how could people have come together
to architect something or something this
complicated
and then have it be successful
well
um
it's a very interesting question uh the
answer is that they basically played
upon the people who have the right
access to power in the right ways and in
particular because of say in the United
States and I know things are a little
different in Canada uh our constitution
makes it very difficult for these kinds
of things to have been put into place
but the corporations can do a lot of
things that the government can't for
example Twitter can curtail your speech
so far because they are a private
company and that's the argument you
usually hear so what actually happened
was there was a collection of corporate
leaders who were brought together that's
what the world economic forum is who met
in this Davos Switzerland and they came
together and they had all of these
Visions for how they could shape society
and go forward but more importantly the
large banking institutions started to
bake into their programs things that
would make sure that that's how
capitalism or business plays out so for
example all of the big leading lenders
and asset managers BlackRock Vanguard
Wells Fargo Goldman Sachs Etc all
require adherence to what they would
call
environmental social and governance
measurements ESG metrics and ESG metrics
are defined in terms of sustainable
development goals so the goal is to make
a sustainable World which sounds great
on paper Until you realize that it means
a heavily managed administered economy
by a technocratic oligarchy in other
words socialism
uh in a new form neosocialism is a
better way to phrase it because it's not
old school socialism it's something
completely different and so if you want
to have your assets managed or to do
business with one of those major lenders
or even through a central bank you
better have a proper ESG score so
there's been if in effect a social
credit score already
put into place for these big companies
and the model they were sold was that
corporations have lost their way they're
no longer being socially responsible so
that we have to have responsible
governance models put into place and
we're going to shift a little bit at
first out of this idea that the
corporation's primary obligation is to
its shareholders which are the people
who own stakes in the company into
something broader called stakeholders
which involve all of these people who
are say technocrats who say you know
what we have a stake in what your Exxon
Mobil does and with regard to pollution
with regard to environmental controls we
the people of whoever you know whether
it's you know some representative of the
UN whether it's some John Kerry or
something has a stake and what happens
with the climate
so Exxon Mobil we're going to score you
in terms of your ability to have your
assets managed and moved and to be able
to do business at the highest levels in
accordance to whether your environmental
score is good and we have to be socially
responsible we can't keep using
capitalist methods to generate
large-scale social and economic
inequities so we have to implement a
social responsibility score under the
social metric and if you want to know
how to do best practices under this new
system the stakeholder system you're
going to have to have best practices and
Company governance and so that's the
governance score and so the way that it
happened was people largely thinking
most of them involved probably thought
they were doing something good and maybe
all of them did I don't even necessarily
want to say oh call Schwab evil maybe he
is maybe he is I don't know I'm not
going to just point to somebody and say
evil for sure what I'm going to say is
even if it started out good it just it's
a it's a ball that is rolled down the
hill to the point now where it's
actually causing problems and nobody's
willing to back out
um
it got out of control because I had
power corrupts over time as it tends to
do and most of this power being that it
was done through non-governmental
organizations and GEOS in conjunction
with State leaders and corporate leaders
is unaccountable power I can't get
pissed off and go vote Claus Schwab out
of the world economic Forum it's his
entity I don't know if it's a non-profit
whatever it is it's his entity I can't
vote him out I have no accountability
there I can't cast my vote for George
Soros not to fund the African-American
policy Forum which is dumping critical
race Theory into the into into society
at an alarming rate I have no say over
where George Soros throws his money
yes he is the chief funder of the
African-American policy Forum which is
run by Kimberly Crenshaw which is uh who
is the person who named critical race
Theory in 1989 in the first place
I don't know why this makes me laugh
it turns out you don't need very many
people if they come up with a way to get
a whole bunch of other people thinking
they're doing the right thing while
you're actually leading them around by
the nose you just don't need very many
people and they don't even have to be
coordinating
George Soros can have his agenda with
all of his money and be leading people
in a particular direction and Klaus
Schwab or Christine Lagarde at the
international monetary fund can be doing
in there and they're in cahoots for sure
I mean they openly like introduce each
other inside each other and appear
together frequently they can have their
own agenda and those might run kind of
in parallel they might feed off of each
other they might sometimes support each
other they might sometimes partner and
sometimes not the Koch brothers or
there's only one left uh dip in and out
of this for example sometimes they're in
it and sometimes they're not uh so it
doesn't take very many people to start
creating a situation where lots of money
and lots of opportunity and I think the
opportunity is bigger than the money
um for example what is the world
economic Forum it's an it's an
opportunity what is Davos what is that
meeting in Davos it's a it's a place for
all the biggest movers and shakers in
the world to get specially invited to
come to this super cool thing
it's going to be lavish and exciting and
fun and you know whatever and rub elbows
and network with one another
networks are really the thing of the
21st century or at least for the time
being and given being given access to
rub elbows with other super smart and
powerful people
as long as you kind of play by the
overarching rules they get you in the
room in the first place
creates an incredible pressure to get
people to go along with something that
it sounds exciting and new and good and
fun and you need very few people if any
who are actually genuinely evil or
agenda driven to really set the tone the
person who's inviting you like anybody
do you need anybody evil there or could
this not take a bunch of influential
people that are trying to do good and
just it could be that yeah it could
actually be that and then you can
imagine though that if there are any
evil people present at all
then that that's going to be the thing
but it's very is it it becomes a country
club like it's like the the country club
like Davos is that the davo set is like
the country club of country clubs of
country clubs it's the Who's Who and I'm
important and I'm big and special or it
has been for many many years and so all
of a sudden you can create within a
country club you always end up creating
an echo chamber especially of values of
what those people espouse what they see
in the world what they want to do and
you can just very easily imagine where
um there's no Pied Piper necessarily
this is actually a thing in Psychology
that's known as the Abilene Paradox uh
where everybody thinks that everybody
else wants to go in a particular
direction but nobody necessarily does so
they all just kind of walk together you
can imagine like if you and a bunch of
friends nobody really wanted to go to
Taco Bell but somehow it was like are we
going to Taco Bell and yeah I thought we
were oh and nobody wants to be the one
to speak up and say what no and so all
of a sudden you know four or five of
your Taco Bell at two in the morning and
you're like how did we get here
everybody's privately thinking how did
we get here
but it's probably Waffle House at 2AM
but um you know
nobody actually wanted to go but
everybody went so there doesn't
necessarily have to be a Pied Piper but
you can imagine how much worse it is if
there is a Pied Piper if say cloud
Schwab has this weird agenda and he says
well the people I'm going to invite to
this Hyper Elite special thing are
people who I can get to go along with my
agenda and if they stop I won't invite
them anymore or I'll cut them off at the
knees in some other way or I'll mobilize
the group to a to a um excommunicate
them you create the exact kinds of
social pressures that human beings are
uh susceptible to at the most tribal
level and you can create
a cabal around an agenda very easily
they might the conspiracy might be
literally one person and everybody else
is just going along because they want to
stay in the social club
that would be crazy
it's just an entire pyramid one person
at the top yeah I encourage people to
read Klaus Schwab's books they're not
hard to read
he is a we'll say Visionary with our
tongue planted firmly in our cheek
he's had a very clear vision for the
world through a fourth Industrial
Revolution which is going there's kind
of big points our fourth Industrial
Revolution in which we're going to move
away from a labor-based economy more or
less entirely everything will be
automated and the problem that they're
then trying to solve is this creates a
many billion strong useless class to be
compared against the creative class that
gets to do the creative and fun things
while machines do the vast majority of
the work so what do you do with those
people well you need methods of social
control and management because they have
nothing to work for how do you justify
paying them well we need Universal basic
income blah blah blah blah blah
that's a thing so you have the idea of a
fourth Industrial Revolution he has this
idea of a public-private partnership
that's running a stakeholder or an
impact capitalism
um and that's where you end up with your
ESG stuff now you have stakeholders who
are going to judge how corporations are
going to do things we're going to
reinvent we're going to reinvent
capitalism to be run through this kind
of technocratic means through these you
know unelected experts in some kind of a
stakeholder meeting
rather than through shareholders who
actually have skin in the game in terms
of what the company is doing in terms of
making a success or not
um he has another idea that what we're
going to go toward in terms of
sustainability is what he calls a
circular economy
this has been warned about by leftists
since the 1960s and specifically the
neo-marxists in the 1960s were warning
that cap consumer capitalism it said
meets people's needs they were admitting
that capitalism Works once you control
for trusts of certain kinds so if you
control for trust capitalism meets
people's needs and they said well what
happens is if you meet people's basic
needs they get new needs and those needs
become less and less needy in some sense
and so then you create an arbitrary kind
of false economy that's just people
producing stuff people don't need so
that people can buy stuff that they
don't really want and then if we look at
that as a level of false needs then
there's a you know this just continues
and continues and continues until
finally the entire thing becomes
unsustainable we exhaust the the world
of its resources and we exhaust people
completely and they are unaware that
their that capitalism is on an
unsustainable growth course so I would
say as somebody who studied mathematical
epidemiology and mathematical ecology
when I was in graduate school that they
don't understand how carrying capacities
actually affect
um real populations and that these
things actually do have a nice natural
smooth curve the the curves are almost
always sigmoid in shape and that this
this these kinds of population Dynamics
are not actually unmanageable
exponential catastrophes where
everything destroys itself in the end it
we tend not to actually populations tend
not actually to destroy themselves by
overpopulation unless maybe you're
talking about bacteria or something that
has absolutely no capacity to cognate so
he wants to move into a circular economy
rather than a linear or exponential
economy so everything reduced reuse
recycle everything has to everything
that comes out of the economy has to
feed back in as the next cycle but
because of the law the second law of
Thermodynamics entropy
always increases that's not really going
to work this is a program of managed
Decline and if again you read say
one-dimensional man Herbert marcuso the
kind of big critical theorist of the 60s
and one dimensional man he even talks
about how
um and initials in Britain in 1964 you
know a sustainable future requires or of
course is of course it requires a
reduction in the future population
um because we have too many people and
it's unsustainable and you see these
things running away so now what we have
to do is this kind of this managed
decline where he says we're going to be
con content with less content with less
gadgets less plastic these are the
actual things he says and that we have
to find where our quality of life can be
raised in other ways rather than having
consumer capitalism Drive everything off
of a cliff and so in that regard I
actually think it's driven whether these
people are evil or not is fine whatever
that's a strong word but it's driven by
lunatics who don't understand how the
world works and that they're very afraid
that we're either with the climate or
with whatever else going to create an
unsustainable situation that leads to
mass extinct mass extinction and they're
trying to save the world from that so
again we come back to this pretext of
safety
but what are we trading have you been to
China it's an interesting country
um I've been to China for I've spent 14
weeks of my life in China and I would
not want to live there it's interesting
to visit
um but the social credit thing is is
intense
okay James
sorry I scared the crap out probably
my eyes are shaking you just can't see
it on camera yeah um yeah this is this
is the uh this is the moment
where everything is meant to be
reorganized and everything is meant to
be reorganized into one where
um social control is absolutely
necessary whether that's control of
information which they just call
misinformation or whatever through
censorship or what Marcus or warned us
is the Need For pre-censorship Less the
idea even enter the head
of people who might be reactionary to
what's going on whether for him the left
agenda the new Left agenda
um whether it's in in terms of you know
who did you hang out with who did you
spend time with how do you behave
whatever did you decide that you were
you know what it's Friday night I ain't
got nothing to do tomorrow I'm gonna
have a good evening you know and party
it up or whatever well that was
irresponsible now you can't like buy a
plane ticket for three weeks or whatever
um there's also an element of this where
there's the gigantic InterContinental
competition uh there are people who in
the west who are very afraid that the
Chinese model is more efficient and
successful what it was called dengism if
we were Trudeau
yes exactly and you hear it from other
Western leaders as well
um so the model that China uses is
called denism
it is a public private partnership where
they've opened up it was Pioneer Deng as
ding Xiaoping it was pioneered by Deng
Xiaoping and the idea was that we're
going to open up the markets but the
market is going to operate at the
pleasure of the party so Jack ma can
become a billionaire and do crazy things
and launches big huge the big world's
biggest new IPO but he said something
critical of the Chinese party Wiley was
launching it and all of a sudden his IPO
doesn't get launched and he disappears
for several months when he comes back
nobody knows if he's dead but when he
finally comes back he's not a
billionaire anymore he's not really all
that rich
um because he said the wrong thing
because he would against the party so
what you're actually seeing there when
they're looking over at China if you
want to put in the terms of 1984 they
see that East Asia already exists
but we don't have Oceania to go up
against it so they have to create
Oceania on this side so that it can
always be at war with East Asia so in
other words we're looking at how do we
turn the West into the they're saying
basically that freedom and democracy and
republics are too inefficient to compete
with an autocracy that has an open
market and so how do we create our own
autocracy that can move and react as
quickly and responsively to things as
say the Chinese government can
while uh
not being China and so everybody's like
you know looking at the world and they
don't understand for example that China
just named George Soros a terrorist and
George Soros has probably done some
things to strike back and I won't
speculate too deeply on what those
things are but it was weird that it was
soon after that that their housing
market took a gigantic multi-trillion
dollar hit and which is a very George
Soros kind of thing to do how do you
sleep at night
do you sleep you get really tired and
then you just black out and have bad
dreams
okay James where can people find you
online
uh the websites new discourses.com I
don't I don't actually talk about this
side of stuff nearly as much as I do
just about the woke stuff because it
turns out the woke is the lock pick to
make this stuff work it's like to open
the door so we can do all this crap so I
mostly talk about the woke stuff also
that's where my literature reading is
all but that's all on new discourses.com
it's on social media in a lot of places
at new discourses go look you can find
it probably at whatever social media
place you like unless it's one of the
ones that I don't want to deal with yet
and eventually I'll expand probably by
force I'm personally on Twitter at
conceptual James and I'm very irreverent
and I tweet way too much and
um
Welcome to the Jungle if you sign up for
following me on Twitter it's fun
okay thank you very much for coming on
yeah sorry to scare the living [ __ ] out
of you this episode is brought to you by
the best grill I have ever used hands
down no questions asked as you know Mom
Dad and I are on this beef and lamb diet
for our really awful autoimmune
disorders so we're very experienced at
cooking meat very but I've never done it
with a grill this classy schwank grills
you guys may have thought I'd switch
brands from blazing bull to swag but
Swank is blazing Bowl's new name I don't
do continuity errors
schweight girls are made in America
they're portable they're an infrared
grill that heats up to 1500 degrees
Fahrenheit to give you that premium
Steakhouse quality taste you know when
there's a crispy layer on the outside
while still being rare or medium rare on
the inside mired reactions this girl
does that but in your backyard or on
your patio does it smoke it's super easy
to clean which is amazing and it makes
high quality Steakhouse style steaks or
whatever else you feel like grilling
steaks take around three minutes to
grill depending on the thickness three
minutes for a restaurant style steak but
you can also do chicken wings fish
hamburgers vegetables or you can use the
pizza stone if you're one of them Pizza
eaters for a nice crispy pizza in under
five minutes try their special offer by
heading to schwank grills.com right now
for 150 off a schwank 1500 degree Grill
when using promo code MP at checkout for
the code to work you must have the
schweight grill and grill cover in your
cart
that'll get you 150 off schweight girls
with code MP at checkout this episode is
brought to you by paleo Valley 100
grass-fed beef sticks paleo Valley is
unique among protein products in the U.S
they're committed to making high quality
clean products free of problematic
ingredients and free from farming
practices that are harmful to the
environment you've probably heard some
of the tricks used by companies did you
know that they can claim their beef is
grass-fed as long as it was fed Grass at
one point in its life
learn something new every day or that
meat can be marked American made even if
it's only packaged in America paleo
Valley on the other hand is the real
deal their products come from small
family-owned farms in the U.S that use
rotational grazing look it up I'm a huge
fan of rotational grazing and their cows
are never fed grains or harmful
antibiotics so if you avoid meat for
environmental reasons which is not a
good reason to avoid meat but if you do
you're gonna love these guys
paleo Valley grass-fed and finished beef
sticks I can't quite eat these because
of my strict meat and salt diet but the
ingredients in here are amazing there
are no preservatives or fillers just 100
American 100 grass-fed and finished beef
from domestic regenerative farms and
organic spices good luck finding
anything this good if you're trying to
get healthy or lose weight an easy way
to do that is just to swap your snacks I
really recommend doing that get rid of
the chips and cookies in your house and
fill your house with paleo valleys beef
sticks go ahead and help your body U.S
farms and the environment today by
trying paleo Valley's high quality
protein just head to paleovalley.com and
enter code MP for 15 off your first
order that's paleovalley.com with code
MP for 15 off your first order enjoy the
rest of the episode
Arthur Kaplan welcome to the podcast
thank you very much for having me before
we get started can you give a brief
background about who you are and what it
is you do absolutely so I'm a professor
I've been at NYU in New York City in our
medical school for about 10 years now
and I started our program in medical
ethics bioethics and often people are
saying that's nice what's that so what
we do is we teach ethics courses to our
medical students that are required they
learn about informed consent privacy the
uh right to refuse Medical Treatments
how to share data what's permissible
what isn't what they have to report to
Public Health authorities in terms of
child abuse or uh sadly
crimes gunshot victims that sort of
stuff and we get into issues of
rationing health care I think you know
Michaela there's been a lot of rationing
going on because of covid of different
types of yes and medical resources we
try to teach about how to think about
that we're are interested in assisted
suicide which has been a big issue in
the United States and Canada when could
you ever ask a doctor to help a dying
person die and could that happen to a
child or someone who's uh mentally
disabled could they participate in these
kinds of things and we do a lot of
research sorry to babble on about this
but it just my interest listeners so we
study things like transplants how will
the people understand organ donation
when someone says do you want to be an
organ donor do they really the family
understand what's happening are they
satisfied that they were treated well so
we'll do surveys questionnaires
interviews we have a big project going
this is kind of interesting on uh
reproductive Technologies
for example I don't know if you know
your listeners know but it's possible to
take sperm from a dead body and
sometimes people
Partners wives will say my husband who
is healthy he had a terrible heart
attack out of the blue or had a stroke
and I still want to have his baby and we
can
technologically wow remove sperm but
should we that man who died never said I
want to have a baby when I'm dead
there's no permission if you will you
listen to the wife or the girlfriend and
they said well we really were trying to
have the baby yeah and you know trust us
that's what we want to do and you're
thinking
do you take that seriously so anyway
we're trying to survey both the medical
people who do it people who come in for
in vitro fertilization treatment we're
just asking them as a kind of
Representative group is this something
you would know about think about ever do
so without taking up the whole podcast
uh we have a lot of fun interesting
exciting areas that we study and publish
about and we also have a master's degree
you could take a master's degree in
bioethics now at NYU wow okay I might
have to have you back on to do a longer
podcast that sounds fascinating but
interesting stuff there
okay so I wanted to talk on this episode
specifically about the vaccine passport
issue okay the ethics behind that so my
first question here
is this vaccine the introduction of a
vaccine passport how do you feel about
that ethically well you're talking to
somebody who's been
pro-vaccine passports for a while now I
didn't get to this late early on I
started to say look
you're going to need to have some way to
prove you're vaccinated if we're going
to have freedom to travel so the biggest
reason to get a vaccine passport going
is many countries are saying you can't
come in here unless you're vaccinated
I'm not going to say whether they're
right or wrong it's just how it is so if
you want to visit Greece if you want to
go to well just many countries
they're going to say show me proof of
vaccination now the way we're stuck
doing it in the United States is you
pull out these little paper cards that
you get when you get vaccinated they're
not even laminated I mean they weren't
even meant for this purpose so I think
you need to have something that you can
stick on your passport card or some chip
or something that says I'm vaccinated
remember to many businesses they do
International Commerce big companies
they got to send their sales people or
their Workforce or their I.T people all
around the world
a lot of the world is saying you can't
come here by the way that's true in the
U.S we're saying you can't enter and you
can't also immigrate unless you have
proof of vaccination so we're looking
for it as well
so better to have a standardized card
hard to forge some of you can't
counterfeit
um just for international purposes
that's probably the strongest argument
what about people who don't want to get
vaccinated
look I'm never going to make anybody get
vaccinated
you don't have to do it I'm not sending
out the vaccine police to hold you down
and sort of give you a vaccine while you
scream that you don't want it but what
happens with people who don't want to
vaccinate and this is odd they lose some
of their freedom I think we hear a lot
of debates saying I have to be free to
decide whether or not to vaccinate I
wouldn't disagree
it is your body you can decide what you
want to put in there but if the business
says you can't come in without
vaccination let's say your gym or your
restaurant or whatever it is or your
employer says look you're not working
here without vaccination and by the way
employers are free to do that they
think about having a job they can fire
you for a thousand Reasons out of the
blue it's what we call at will you know
you're employed unless you have a
contract or some special arrangement
you you work at the discretion of the
company the company decides for whatever
reason you got to be vaccinated then you
can't go there so what I'm saying is
this
well we sometimes argue ethically we
have to be free to choose okay but
remember you're going to have more
freedom to work and go places in a world
that's starting to expect vaccination in
a lot of settings you can make the
choice say I don't care and I won't work
there and I'm not going to go into those
places that want me to prove it okay but
I think weirdly
it's it's it's pretty likely that you're
going to get more freedom long-term from
vaccinating than not
okay what about the concern whether or
not this is a conspiracy theory who
knows but what about the concern that
the vaccine passport is part of a bigger
picture and will end up with a social
credit system like China yeah well the
Chinese system for listeners don't know
they're using face recognition they're
monitoring movements all over the place
by the way they also test your genes
they have all these genetic database on
who's a weaver and who's not and part of
the way they lock up people they don't
like is to use a genetic test so
another show that's really abusive of
Human Rights they're monitoring their
citizens day and night
if we had a vaccine passport or we
sliding down that road is basically the
worry I don't think so because I think
we can say
in the middle of a plague we need these
vaccine passports
when the plague goes away we're done
with them that is we're not going to do
them anymore but we should pass
legislation that makes it clear we're
responding to covet this is not an
effort to let the state start to know
where we are the other sad point is this
and it is sad
uh I'm holding up right now my cell
phone and people constantly are saying
to me I don't want a vaccine passport
because people will know where I am
you know what the cell phone does it
transmits every minute where I am to a
slew of people not just hackers but my
credit card company my bank somebody
does OpenTable and makes reservations at
rest they know where I am all the time
this thing is a GPS it tracks me
constantly I would worry about that area
of privacy more I mean I'm on board to
say we gotta protect your privacy but
the vaccine passport is like
a one percent risk relative to your
credit card your cell phone
um your Uber registration uh what
Facebook knows about you I mean my God
there's like
there's a hundred different companies
right now that know
everything about me uh where I look on
the web where I go and we haven't done
anything about that
uh are you aware of so you're in New
York what's New York like if you're not
vaccinated and you don't have one of
these cards
nasty this is a place that's very
pro-vaccine as I am to be uh honestly
I've been vaccinated I've even had a
third shot I just got my flu shot you're
talking did you get the booster shot
after the first two like after six
months or something okay partly uh just
because I'm old enough to qualify uh
that's really why I did it uh partly
because I do go to places where there
are unvaccinated people around both well
just in a lot of my job related work in
the hospital and stuff and then whether
it's a wedding or a sporting event I
don't know who's really vaccinated or
not people say they are I don't know
maybe they are maybe they aren't so I'm
being cautious that way all that said
New York has mandates and they are very
uh they're seriously applied I would say
a lot of restaurants bars gyms
um cafes you can't get in unless you can
show a vaccine passport unless you have
authentication they won't serve you and
they won't let you in
there have been fights about it people
have gotten into big screaming arguments
about getting in but they do try to
enforce a city-wide mandate on access to
public uh places
teachers mandated city workers mandated
they're talking now about mandating
vaccinations for prison guards and the
police the mayor's on here constantly
promoting vaccination but the real test
of this I mean what are we trying to do
not just trying to vaccinate people
trying to get less disease and where I
work less people in the hospital so I
see the results of non-vaccination
because our beds are full when the
epidemic is out of control a lot of
people sick a lot of people dying
pressure on
the ICU beds that we have in around the
New York hospitals right now Alaska for
example is in the middle of a huge
outbreak and they don't have enough ICU
beds and they don't have enough doctors
to treat all the people coming in so
it's bad
the mandates here have reduced that the
real question to me is I don't care what
the vaccination rate is what I want to
know is are there fewer people getting
sick so so far it looks like our rates
are probably 80 vaccination and I think
it's having an impact even the U.S
70 roughly vaccinated at this point of
adults kids are going to be see what
happens with them soon but they're going
to become eligible but covet is starting
to get weaker fewer cases fewer deaths I
think it's working
what do you think of the ethics behind
not pressuring people to be vaccinated
with a newer vaccine like this
especially yeah that's a really good
question so
a lot of people worry
let's see these are new vaccines uh
Pfizer moderna the Johnson and Johnson
one is a little older style vaccine
that's been around a little more that's
the two shot one but the new you know a
lot of people are offered Pfizer and
moderna and it is true that the
description that was used by then
president Trump for them was warp speed
and I think a lot of people are thinking
Hmm I'm not sure I want my medicine at
warp speed or my vaccine at warp speed
so here's what's going on
I'll give you the story The vaccines
moderna and uh Pfizer had are not warp
speed science
you've got uh Canada had a big SARS
outbreak
yeah there were MERS outbreaks different
diseases they're all cousins to covet
they're all in that same What's called
the SARS family of viruses and they were
working on these platforms to make
vaccines for about 10 years they'd
already done the animal studies they
tested the same technology and healthy
volunteers
that's why you were able to go fast if
we hadn't been doing that
there wouldn't have been any vaccines to
approve because they would have had to
start from scratch and start animal
studies and all this so they've done all
that what's warp speed is the US
government said we're going to buy
vaccines from you big Pharma companies
whether they work or not you're going to
get paid big Pharma company said hey
great you give us billions of dollars
we'll make a lot of these vaccines
that's the warp speed it's the
manufacturing normally would take them
forever years to commit to making a lot
of vaccine now they said you're giving
us the money whether it works or not
we're in Happily they worked but the
Speedy part is making them faster so the
companies make money they did
is there a potential to say they have a
conflict of interest in promoting
vaccination yeah you could although I do
think we're getting a demonstration as
covid begins to
dip that they're working did the
companies get overpaid
I think so should they start to be
cutting the price I think so should they
be doing something to make vaccines
available in poor countries I think so
they're not so I'm not excusing their
behavior but I don't worry about the
science
I think the science of sound and you
know at this point one other comment
a couple of billion people have had
vaccination around the world if it was
really dangerous we'd know
okay so you talked about vaccine
passports and what would be potentially
reasonable would be implementing the
passport while we're in the middle
of a pandemic and then having some of
these rights
back potentially for and and correct me
if I'm paraphrasing wrong but having
some of these rights back maybe for
unvaccinated people once numbers are
lower yeah I mean I think that's I think
you know look we have the flu
in any given year it might kill as many
as 25 30 000 people in the U.S I don't
know the worldwide numbers but it's not
trivial but no one's getting a passport
no one's saying you can't come in here
if you're not vaccinated against the flu
there are days when I think maybe we
should do that just to get more flu
protection but look
all of us have to come to an agreement
I'm going to use a U.S number again 725
000 people dead in a year is too big
got to get tough gonna try and control
that 25 000 people dying is a little bit
more like Automobiles and we don't ban
them we just kind of try to make it
safer I'm not saying we don't
do anything but we live with the fact
that a lot of people die in car
accidents and that's how it is and
that's what we do with the flu if we
could drive covid down to that level
then I think we're kind of out of the
woods and we don't have to have special
laws and mandates and religious
exemptions and all these fights we're
getting into
it's that big number
close to 750 000 people dead a hospital
system in around the world that's been
hugely strained very expensive
um think about the economic impact you
know we tried to do quarantines and
lockdowns in many countries like New
Zealand Australia the world economy
almost fell apart
um that's that's a much bigger problem
that makes me want to do a bigger
response if you will to have vaccine
passports and pro-vaccination it's the
numbers
what happened so you you think that the
vaccines are helping I feel like and I'm
not not aware of the numbers I thought
in Canada and I could be wrong but I
thought that the numbers were Rising
again and I think we have an about an 80
vaccination rate but
so should we be looking at numbers or
should we be looking at how severe the
disease is so in the U.S
40 reduction in hospitalizations in the
past couple of weeks and
many fewer cases although we don't
really have a national testing program
so it's a little hard to say or they're
fewer infected people we're basically
tracing to answer your questions
symptoms
who uh sick enough to get to the
hospital because that's where we have
numbers so that is the measure
okay and there's been a reduction in
Alaska yeah it's really shifting you see
it
um
and by the way I'm going to confess to
something else
there's a lot of vaccination out there
but something else has happened there
are also a lot of people who got coded
and have some natural yeah yeah so I had
coveted twice did you
yeah it was fairly unpleasant yeah I was
gonna say what what happened what was
your experience the first time I was
sick for about two and a half weeks but
it was really not that bad I had a fever
off and on and I it really wasn't that
bad I have a toddler so I get some of
the horrible things she drives oh sure
little agents of infection yeah yeah
gross but anyway so the first time it
wasn't that bad and then I was like okay
I'm gonna be immune for a while and then
I got it again about a year later and it
was quite nasty it was about two weeks
so it didn't last for as long but I had
a wheeze I didn't end up in the hospital
I wasn't taking any medication or
anything but I was completely wiped out
and I still don't have my sense of smell
or taste back and I had it in June
so one other reason to worry about covid
as you think about vaccination versus
and whatever the risks and worries are
about that versus coven my wife got it
too and she was uh infected before we
had vaccines she runs a huge hospital
here in New York the Bronx VA he went to
work every day
pre-vaccinations it was around plenty of
people who were infected she got it
hasn't had her uh full sense of smell
and taste restored even now it's been
over how long no it's not really here
she's tired easily I think we don't
understand yet what this damn virus does
long term to the people who get I'm not
saying it's the same for everybody she's
older than you so maybe younger people
do better but
uh you know this people have underlying
diseases they're more prone to get
complications I worry that Covenant
infection might trigger bad responses in
someone with Ms or diabetes or other
things we don't know we just don't know
so that could be an additional
reason to go for the vaccine even if
you're like oh I don't know I don't like
vaccines
you don't want to get stuck with this
long-term covet problem
yeah the so some of the arguments you
hear on the other side are questions
about the efficacy of the vaccine so
whether or not it's actually helping
because say in in Canada well how many
what percentage of the people in
hospitals that end up in hospitals are
vaccinated is this actually reducing the
severity of symptoms are we sure about
that yeah we're sure that if you look
I'm in Connecticut where I live here's
the number in the ICU
vaccinated people are excuse me
unvaccinated people are there at a
frequency of 50 times vaccinated people
wow so it's huge
you're not going to get in the ICU if
you've accidentally not saying you
wouldn't get some symptoms I'm not
saying people can't catch it and but
it's it really
it makes you less Sick by the way you
know something interesting that's
exactly what the flu vaccine does people
say to me all the time I got vaccinated
I got the flu
and I say to them so how long were you
sick and they say I don't know a day
most people get the Fluor out of it for
five days they're bedridden they got
aches and pains it's miserable yeah you
could still get the flu but part of what
these vaccines are doing is if the
body's immune system can't be bumped up
enough to fight off completely the virus
it still helps to diminish the symptoms
so that's a that's one for the vaccines
there I think but yeah we really do know
the numbers there because we can survey
who's in the ICU we know
should there be exemptions for people
who have natural immunity and is natural
immunity more effective at fighting
covid then yeah well here's something
bananas the same mechanisms of natural
immunity or what you get out of a
vaccine they're operating the same way
it's not like natural for immunity is
better than vaccine immunity so like
that's unnatural you're using the same
cells to try and get an immune response
it's it's weird
so I like I said I don't really know
what I'm talking about but I thought
that the vaccine worked and it only
provoked part of an immune response
compared to Contracting covid is that
wrong I know what you're asking there so
when you get the disease you might
trigger let's say there are five parts
of your immune system there are T cells
and B cells and all kinds of stuff that
we don't have to get into here and when
you get sick if you get a big exposure
to covid you probably get them all
triggered if you only get a little
exposure you walk by somebody a couple a
few viruses get into you you're not
setting that all off oh if you get the
vaccine it does set off all of the uh
immune responses so the argument is you
might have partial protection in some
instances natural infection true but
you're going to get the full ride if you
take the vaccine because the way it's
designed is to basically set off the
whole immune response so that's what the
difference is are there people out there
maybe you who had you know serious
exposure to covet and twice whose immune
system is operating about the same level
as a vaccine could be there are other
people though who they just get a
sniffle they don't even know they got
infected I don't think their immune
system was
triggered fully they didn't have enough
virus to set the whole thing off so
that's where the argument is are there
people
who probably don't need it yeah but it's
interesting too you know we're talking
about third shots
some people say well the vaccine isn't
that good if it needs a third shot what
the heck didn't work
I think it's a three-shot vaccine for
listeners who've had any vaccines
if you get HPV vaccine for cervical
cancer which young women and boys do
it's three shots
spaced out over a year and a half
if you get a vaccine for Hepatitis which
is a great vaccine to get because you
really don't want to damage your liver
spaced out three shots polio vaccine
which by the way isn't really a vaccine
it's an oral thing but it's four things
for kids over I don't know two years my
point being when we develop these
vaccines we were so desperate to get
something that would stop deaths that
they gave one shot waited two weeks and
gave the second one that's not enough
maybe what we're just talking about is a
three-shot vaccine which is one of the
reasons I decided to get the third shot
I don't even think of it as a booster I
think we were in such a hurry to get
these things out there and they worked
at least they stopped the initial wave
of covid okay ethically I agree
but it could be that we need three shots
to make this thing work and then we can
argue about boosters but if the three
shots give you immunity for three years
five years that's what you want I don't
know about you but almost everybody has
had a tetanus shot in their life even
that needs a booster 10 years yeah yeah
I think I I was tested recently for I
can't remember I can't remember I think
it was part of the MMR vaccine one of
them had worn off they do they do you
normally don't worry about it because
there's so little measles and bumps
floating around that you know when you
get reminded about those when you travel
if you went in and said I'm gonna go to
Mozambique or I've got which I did a
couple years ago I got a a medical trip
and a vacation lined up there every
booster was I must have had this will
terrifying listeners I think I had like
eight shots you know typhus typhoid all
kind of yellow fever
I didn't worry me too much because those
are pretty well established vaccines but
they were all basically boosters
okay that's fair yeah well going to some
of those places I can understand why
yeah
having been there by the way I fully
understand why now a lot of disease
yeah
okay you I believe wrote an article
about people who were refusing
potentially people who refused to take
the covid-19 vaccine being held
financially liable
is that something you still believe yeah
oh yeah
I still do and here's why
if you knew that your kid was covered
positive and you sent them to school and
the people they sat next to their kids
got sick you ought to be responsible for
the decision not to keep them home or
you know say uh at least you got to go
in with a mask or maybe even notify the
class that my kid's positive but coming
in anyway
so what I was talking about is people
who deliberately
no they're uh sick but still go to work
or still go to school we have a law like
that in the U.S I'm not sure about
Canada if you know that you are HIV
positive and you still have sex with
somebody you're liable
if they try not are they trying to I've
heard somewhere that that was trying to
be appealed
of the AIDS thing yeah yeah maybe it
could be there haven't been many
prosecutions because the situation
happily is rare
you got to be kind of a malignant idiot
to do that but uh yeah it comes up a
little bit too
we had a big trial here the R Kelly
trial remember that the guy yeah yeah
so a lot of the women said he gave me
herpes and he knew he was positive and
that became part of the lawsuit
so I'm in that Spirit that's what I'm
talking about here it's like I'm not
saying
just anybody wandering around but if you
knew that you were sick and you went in
and sat in a small office with somebody
and they got sick and they sort of said
well the only person that's positive
that I've been around is you
that's where you might get some
liability
um do you do you think that the vaccine
passport ethically
okay so you're not you're not allowed
and I think it's in the Constitution but
I could be wrong because I'm not
American but
you're not allowed to ask for Health
Data right that's your personal data so
do you think the vaccine passport
crosses into that territory no
so we have a Privacy Law HIPAA that was
passed in 1996.
it actually was passed before Google
it's way out of date by the way but the
only thing it applies to is what doctors
and nurses and health care workers can
release it has no authority over what
the state or the city can ask you for or
if you choose to give out health
information anyway so a doctor is told
you can't release records you can't say
anything about you know Michaela's care
it's private you need her permission I
mean they could do it if you said okay
there are plenty of people Bill Clinton
went in the hospital yesterday for some
sort of infection we're not going to
know much about his care unless he says
you can tell people that's what the law
governs doctors and hospitals but
there's no HIPAA protection if the mayor
says you're going to have to show a
passport to get into this restaurant the
law was never
intended as a general Privacy Law it was
about medical records by the way paper
records I mean that law is so old it's
so badly needs update and we could argue
about whether it should be extended
wherever you go or what the police could
demand and so on but right now it's a
very narrow
misunderstood law it applies to me I'm
not supposed to tell you if we had a
celebrity patient that they're there in
the hospital or you know that somebody
has been raped or had a mental illness
or something like that I don't know what
the Canadian equivalent is I just don't
know
I think it's probably something similar
yeah but a lot of these privacy what I'm
saying is a lot of these privacy laws
were enacted before you got a Fitbit and
we're sending health information off to
a company are they prohibited from
sharing that no they're not a doctor
they're not a hospital I guess they
could sell it they could
you know call you up and say I think you
need to get a little more sleep there
Michaela we're looking at your uh
monitoring device we don't like what
we're seeing you know what I mean it's
sort of like it's a free fire zone
are they trying to implement QR codes or
anything in New York
no we have not seen that yet so
everything's paper everything's paper
and easy to counterfeit and it there are
counterfeits
going on out there they've prosecuted a
few people
I am told by some of my students that it
would take you about 30 minutes to make
a pretty good counterfeit of a Kobe card
so
you know that's an issue
yeah yeah okay that and then this this
is definitely an issue while traveling
too I was in Dubai and everyone's back
stay like did Mass vaccination there
everyone's vaccinated there and you need
a vaccine to get into the country I
think Israel was the same when did
Israel Backtrack on that did they
mandate it and then backtrack they they
sort of rolled out vaccine and waves so
they tried to do the elderly that wasn't
enough and they started to adults and
they started to kids so they've had
waves of vaccination
oh but they're pretty much up to the 100
by the way Dubai and the Emirates
they're an interesting case study
because I don't think they've had much
in the way of people in the hospital
yeah
they haven't but they uh when I was
there they said they just like there was
a stadium and people just went in and
got vaccinated you had to get vaccinated
for your job or they just kicked you out
of Dubai they're like well you don't
have to work here
right and remember one other thing in
countries like Dubai or Israel
they're all part of a National Health
System the issues about privacy are less
worrisome to them because they already
have all your medical information it's
run by the government
they can peek in and look at anything
they damn well want Israel too so
there's no divide between Healthcare
over here and government over there
basically the government's running the
health system the government pays for
your health care and they're looking all
the time at what's going on in terms of
cost and payment and so if they want to
I'm sure they can
look at anything they like about your
health
yeah fair enough okay
do I have other questions for you
I don't think so I think that kind of
covers your view pretty well I know you
have a heart out uh I might want to
bring you back on to talk bioethics
we didn't talk about is what about
alternative medicines and approaches to
covet yeah let's do that let's do that
and I'm a you know familiar with
something some things I hate because I
don't think they really
work that there's not evidence for
example that if you took Ivermectin this
deworming pill yeah
there's no reason to think that a pill
that's aimed at killing worms is going
to kill viruses I mean it just doesn't
make sense I know there are a lot of
people swear by and a lot of people say
yeah better uh but
uh
scientifically what kills worms doesn't
kill viruses and at least the published
data that's out there doesn't really see
any benefit from Ivermectin on the other
hand if somebody said to me I want to
use something to boost my immune system
personally I think that's hard to do but
it doesn't hurt you and if you want to
do that okay
I like alternative medicine things that
I think are uh safe so to speak neutral
they don't make you sicker maybe some
people feel they get benefit and that's
fine by me if you want to do
aromatherapy or
you have massage or whatever I mean you
know those sound nice uh are they going
to kill viruses I doubt it but you know
okay so I think medicine can work with
alternative approaches alternative ideas
Health Foods whatever
you just don't want to have people
promoting
certain drugs that are out there
Ivermectin is one of them it is an
approved drug but it's for work
that isn't that isn't where you want to
go uh the thing that helps your sheep or
your cow is probably not the thing
that's going to be right for you to uh
battle coven and when a court says this
patient wants it
my attitude is we don't give it because
it's more dangerous than it is helpful
what about antibody infusions
they work they absolutely do work
problem with them it's expensive so you
could go to them and people are getting
them uh these are the things that
basically are building in antibodies the
way hopefully a vaccine or a natural
infection would produce them you're just
making them and putting them in but they
work it's just they probably cost
twenty thousand dollars you have to get
them IV it's a whole song and dance I
know some people seem to think that's
better
than getting a vaccine but that's a
trade-off I don't like I'd rather get
the vaccine than be sitting there
in the clinic a couple of times to get
antibody infusion
well in any event if you let me out I'm
happy to come back and rant off yeah
I'll let you out I'll let you out thank
you very much for coming on here it was
a pleasure thank you for having me
[Music]